stop doing the things that you know are
wrong
make a damn schedule and stick to it
sometimes
you know oh i can't sleep at night
because i'm thinking about something and
usually what i'll do is go write it down
it's important to distinguish between
those because that's partly and this is
back down to the micro routine analysis
so i'm saying well you're going to try
to make yourself more industrious
okay number one specify your damn goals
because how are you going to hit
something if you don't know what it is
hello believe nation my name is evan
carmichael my one word is believe and i
believe that
entrepreneurs will solve all of the
world's major problems
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from clinical
psychologist
and professor jordan b peterson and my
take on his top 10 rules of success
rule number four is my personal favorite
and i'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always as you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired but you might win a prize as
well
and also when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick for yourself
as well
enjoy
stop doing the things that you know are
wrong
that you could stop doing right so
it's a fairly it's a fairly limited
attempt first of all we're not going to
say that you know
what the good is or what the truth is in
any ultimate sense
but we will presume that there are
things that you're doing that for one
reason other you know are not in your
best interests there's something about
them
that you just know you should stop
they're kind of self-evident to you
other things you're going to be doubtful
about you're not going to know
which way is up and which way is down
but there are things that you're doing
that you know you shouldn't do now some
of those you won't stop doing
for whatever reason you don't have the
discipline or maybe there's a secondary
payoff or
you don't believe it's necessary or it's
too much of a sacrifice or
you're angry or resentful or or afraid
who knows
so forget about those for now but
there's another
subset that you could stop doing it
might be little thing
well that's fine stop doing it and see
what happens
and what will happen is your vision will
clear a little bit
and then something else will pop up in
your field of
apprehension that you will also know you
should stop doing
and that you could stop doing because
you strengthened yourself a bit by
stopping doing the particular stupid
thing that you were doing before
that just puts you together a little bit
more and you could do that
repeatedly for for an indefinite period
of time and
and you know that doesn't necessarily
mean that you're going to ever be able
to formulate a
clear and final picture of what
constitutes the truth
and the good but it does mean that
you'll be able to continually move away
from what's untruth and what's
bad and you know that's not a bad start
make a damn schedule and stick to it
okay so what's the rule with the
schedule
it's not a bloody prison that's the
first thing that people do wrong they
say well i don't like to
follow a schedule it's like well what
kind of schedule are you setting up
well i have to do this then i have to do
this then i have to do this
you know and then i just go play video
games because who wants to do all these
things that i have to do
it's like wrong set the damn schedule up
so that you have the day you want
that's the trick it's like okay i've got
tomorrow if i was going to set it up so
it was the best possible day i could
have
practically speaking what would it look
like
well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day
you're not in worse shape than you were
that than at the beginning of the day
right because that's a stupid day
if you have a bunch of those in a row
you just dig you know you dig yourself a
hole and then you bury yourself in it's
like
sorry that's just not a good strategy
it's a bad strategy
so maybe 20 of your day has to be
responsibility and obligation or maybe
it's more than that depending on how far
behind you are
but even that you can you can ask
yourself okay well i've got these
responsibilities
i have to schedule the damn things in
what's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward
and you can ask yourself that just like
you'd negotiate with someone who is
working for you it's like okay you gotta
work tomorrow
okay so i want you to work tomorrow and
you might say okay well what are you
gonna do for me
that makes it likely that i'll work for
you well you could ask yourself that you
know so maybe you
do an hour of responsibility and then
you play a video game for 15 minutes i
don't know whatever turns your crank
man but you know you have to negotiate
with yourself and not tyrannize yourself
like you're negotiating with someone
that you care for that you would like to
be productive and have a good life and
and that's how you make the schedule
it's like and then you look at the day
and you think well if i had that day
that'd be good
great you know and you you're useless
and horrible so you'll probably only hit
it with about seventy percent accuracy
but
that beats the hell out of zero right
and if you hit it even with fifty
percent accuracy
another rule is well aim for fifty one
percent the next week or fifty and a
half percent for god's sake or
because you're you're going to hit that
position where things start to loop back
positively and spiral you upward
sometimes
you know i can't sleep at night because
i'm thinking about something and
usually what i'll do is go write it down
i have some writing to do so i get up
and i go write down what i'm thinking
and that usually does the trick
but because i had been playing with
youtube i thought
well i'll try making youtube video and
and telling people what i'm thinking
about and see
if that performs the same uh
function as writing and to me the
function of writing well it's twofold
one is
conceivably to communicate with people
although
the fundamental purpose for me is to
clarify my thoughts so that i know
to you know because if you're if
something is disturbing you
what that means is that it needs to be
articulated it what it's the emergence
of unexplored territory
something that disturbs you that that's
the right way to think about it
it's unmapped territory that's
manifesting itself
it's like a vista of threat and
possibility and you need to articulate a
path through it
and so that's what i was doing it's like
i was thinking well this is bothering me
and this seems to be why and here's what
i think is going on and
and so i made the videos and in some
sense i i didn't think
anything more of it you don't have to
necessarily have done anything wrong for
things to get completely out of control
it's a terrifying doctrine but it's not
a hopeless doctrine because it still
says that there's a way forward there's
a pathway forward and the
pathway forward is to adopt a motive
being that has some nobility
so that you can tolerate yourself and
perhaps even have some respect for
yourself as someone
who's capable of standing up in the face
of that terrible vulnerability and
suffering and that the pathway forward
as far as the existentialists are
concerned
is by well certainly by the avoidance of
deceit
particularly in language but also by the
adoption of
responsibility for the conditions of
existence and some attempt on your part
to actually rectify them and the thing
that's so interesting about that is
that well two as far as i'm concerned
and some of this is from clinical
experience you know if you take people
and i've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals
if you can teach people to stand up in
the face of the things they're afraid of
they get stronger and you don't know
what the upper limits to that are
because you might ask yourself like
if for 10 years if you didn't avoid
doing what you knew you needed to do
by the depth by your own definitions
right within the value structure that
you've created
to the degree that you've done that what
would you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do
find out over decades-long periods what
they could be like if they were who they
were
if they said if they spoke their being
forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably
can be left at your feet because you're
not everything you could be and you know
it
and of course that's a terrible thing to
admit and it's a terrible thing to
consider
but there's real promise in it right
because it means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world and the number
another way that you could
act in the world so what it would
reflect back to you would be much better
than what it reflects back to you now
my experience is with people that we're
probably running at about 51
of our capacity something i mean you can
think about this yourselves
i often ask undergraduates how many
hours a day you waste or how many hours
a week you waste and
the classic answer is something like
four to six hours a day
you know inefficient studying uh
watching things on youtube that not only
do you not want to watch that you don't
even care about that make you feel
horrible about watching after you're
done
that's probably four hours right there
you know you think well that's
20 25 hours a week it's 100 hours a
month that's two and a half full work
weeks
it's half a year of work weeks per year
and if your time is worth
20 an hour which is a radical
underestimate it's probably more like 50
if you think about it in terms of
deferred wages if you're wasting
20 hours a week you're wasting fifty
thousand dollars a year
and you are doing that right now and
it's because you're young wasting fifty
thousand dollars a year is a way bigger
catastrophe than it would be for me to
waste it because i'm not gonna last
nearly as long
and so if your life isn't everything it
could be you could ask yourself well
what would happen if you just stopped
wasting the opportunities that are in
front of you
you'd be who knows how much more
efficient 10 times more efficient
20 times more efficient that's the
pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get
it's completely it's off the charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop
making things worse because that's
another thing people do all the time
not only do they not do what they should
to make things better
they actively attempt to make things
worse because they're spiteful or
resentful
or arrogant or deceitful or or homicidal
or genocidal or
all of those things all bundled together
in an absolutely pathological package
if people stopped really really trying
just to make things worse
we have no idea how much better they
would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential
system of ideas between human
vulnerability
social judgment both of which are are
are are major causes of suffering and
the failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility
that they know they should adopt it
isn't merely that
your fate depends on whether or not you
get your act together and
to what degree you decide that you're
going to live
out your own genuine being it isn't only
your fate
it's the fate of everyone that you're
networked with and so you know you think
well
there's nine billion seven billion
people in the world we're going to peak
at about nine billion by the way
and then it'll decline rapidly but seven
billion people in the world and who are
you you're just one little dust
mote among that seven billion and so it
really doesn't matter what you do or
don't do but that's
simply not the case it's the wrong model
because you're at the center
of a network you're a node in a network
of course that's even more true now that
we have social media you'll you
you'll know a thousand people at least
over the course of your life
and they'll know a thousand people each
and that puts you one person away from a
million
and two persons away from a billion and
so that's how you're connected and the
things
you do they're like dropping a stone in
a pond the ripples move outward
and they affect things in ways that you
can't fully comprehend and it means that
the things that you do and that you
don't do are far more important than you
think and so if you act that way of
course the terror of realizing that is
that it actually
starts to matter what you do and you
might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter
but i mean if you really asked yourself
would you be so sure if you had the
choice
i can live with no responsibility
whatsoever the price i pay is that
nothing
matters or i can reverse it and
everything matters
but i have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that
it's not so obvious to me that people
would take the meaningful path
you know when you say well nihilists
suffer dreadfully because there's no
meaning in their life and they still
suffer yeah but the advantage is they
have no responsibility
so that's the payoff and i actually
think that's the motivation say well i
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe maybe you've just allowed
them to collapse because it's a hell of
a lot easier than acting them out
and the price you pay is some
meaningless suffering but you can always
whine about that and people will feel
sorry for you
and you have the option of taking the
pathway of the martyr so that's a pretty
good deal
all things considered especially when
they are when the alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well
what solzhenitsyn figured out and so
many people in the 20th century it's not
just him even though he's the best
example
is that if you live a pathological life
you pathologize your society and if
enough people do that then
it's hell really
really and you can read the gulag
archipelago if you
have the fortitude to do that and you'll
see exactly what hell is like
and then you can decide if that's a
place you'd like to visit
or even more importantly if it's a light
if it's a place you'd like to visit
and take all your family and friends
because that's what happened in the 20th
century
the next best predictor of lifetime
success is conscientiousness
well so and of tho of the two aspects of
conscientiousness say
orderliness and and industriousness the
better predictor is industriousness
so the question is well what can you do
about your industriousness
and the answer to that is well that's
kind of rough too because
there's a strong genetic component but
you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and i
think the best micro habits
this is partly to do with this future
authoring program processes i think the
best thing you can do with regards to
your conscientiousness is to
set up some aims for yourself goals that
you actually value
and the future authoring program helps
people do that
and basically it does a situational
analysis of
it helps you do a situational analysis
of your life more than a psychological
analysis i would say and so
the questions are something like well
all right you're gonna have to put some
effort into your life
and you need to be motivated to do that
and so
what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them in
in the big five manner you know if
you're extroverted you want friends if
you're agreeable you want an intimate
relationship
if you're disagreeable you want to win
competitions if you're open you want to
engage in creative activity if you're
high neuroticism you want security okay
so those are all sources of potential
motivation
that you could draw on that you could
tailor to your own you know your own
personality
but then there are dimensions that you
want to consider your life across and so
we ask people about
well you know if you could have your
life the way you wanted it in three to
five years if you were taking care of
yourself
properly you know what would you want
from your friendships what would you
want from your intimate relationship how
would you like to structure your family
what do you want for your career well
how are you going to use your time
outside of your
job and how are you going to regulate
your mental physical
mental and physical health and maybe
also your drug and alcohol use because
that's
that's a good place to augur down you
know because alcoholism for example
wipes out
you know five to ten percent of people
so you want to keep that
under control and then and then
so maybe you know you you you develop a
vision of what your life
what you would like your life to be and
that associates
the so the goal once the goal is
established and then you break down
the goal into micro processes that you
can implement the micro processes become
rewarding in proportion in relation to
their
uh causal association with the goal and
that tangles in your
your incentive reward system you know we
talked about the dopaminergic incentive
reward system and that's the thing that
keeps you moving forward
and the way it works is that it works
better if
it produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation
working out and so the more valuable the
goal in principle the more the micro
process associated with that goal start
to take on a positive charge
and so what that means is while you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go and so
as far as i can tell what you do is you
specify your long-term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified
to fail as well as excited about
succeeding because that's also useful
you specify your goal you do that
you do that in some sense as a unique
individual you want
you want to specify goals that make you
say oh
if that could happen as a consequence of
my efforts it would clearly be
worthwhile
because the question always is why do
something because doing nothing is easy
you just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy
the question is why would you ever do
anything and the answer that has to be
because you've determined
by some means that it's worthwhile and
then the next question might be well
where should you look for worthwhile
things and one would be well you could
consult your own temperament
and the other would be well you kind of
look at how
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan
look look what so you do a structural
analysis of the subcomponents of human
existence and
already did that you need a family you
need friends
like you don't need to have all these
things but you better have most of them
family friends career educational goals
plans for you know time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad
that's a bad deal for you so
so once you but once you set up that
that goal structure let's say and that's
really in many
in many ways that's what you should be
doing at universities is that's exactly
what you should be doing is trying to
figure out
who it is that you're trying to be
right and you you aim at that and then
you use everything you learn
as a means of building that person that
you want to be and
and i really mean want to be i don't
mean should be even those things
those things are going to overlap and
it's important to distinguish between
those because that's partly and this is
back down to the micro routine analysis
so if i say well you're going to try to
make yourself more industrious
okay number one specify your damn goals
because how are you going to hit
something if you don't know what it is
that isn't going to happen and often
people won't specify their goals too
because they don't like to specify
conditions for failure
so if you keep yourself all vague and
foggy which is real easy because that's
just a matter of not doing as well
then you don't know when you fail and
people might say well i really don't
want to know when i fail because that's
painful
so i'll keep myself blind about when i
fail that's fine except you'll fail all
the time then
you just won't know it until you've
failed so badly that you're done
and that can easily happen by the time
you're 40.
so so i would recommend that you don't
let that happen
so that's willful blindness right you
could have known but you chose not to
okay so once you get your goal structure
set up you think okay if i could have
this
life looks like that might be worth
living despite the fact that it's going
to be
you know anxiety provoking and
threatening and there's going to be some
suffering and loss involved in all of
that
obviously the goal is to to have a
vision for your life
such that all things considered that
justifies your effort
i started to pay very careful attention
to what i was saying
i don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily but i could
feel a sort of split developing in my
psyche and the split and i've actually
had students tell me the same thing
has happened to them after they've
listened to some of the material that
that i've been describing to all of you
but
split into two let's say
and one part was the let's say the old
me
that was talking a lot and that
liked to argue and that liked ideas and
there was another part that was
watching that part like just with its
eyes open
and neutrally judging and the part that
was neutrally judging
was watching the part that was talking
and going that isn't your idea
you don't really believe that you don't
really know what you're talking about
that isn't true and i thought hmm that's
really interesting so now i've and that
was happening to like 95
of what i was saying and so then i
didn't really know what to do i thought
okay this is strange so
maybe i've fragmented and that's just
not a good thing at all
i mean it wasn't like i was hearing
voices or anything like that i mean
it wasn't like that it was it was
well people have multiple parts
so then i had a this weird conundrum is
like well which of these
two things are me is it the part that's
listening and saying
no that's rubbish that's a lie that's
you're doing that to impress people
you're just trying to win the argument
you know
was that me or was the part that was
going about my normal
verbal business me and i didn't know but
i decided i would go with the critic
and then what i'd tried to do what i
learned to do i think
was to stop saying things that made me
and now that i mean i'm still trying to
do that because i'm always
feeling when i talk whether or not the
words that i'm saying are either making
me
align or making me come apart and i
think the alignment i really do think
the alignment
is i think alignment is the right way of
conceptualizing it because i think if
you say things that are
as true as you can say them let's say
then
they come up they come out of the depths
inside of you
because we don't know where thoughts
come from we don't know how far down
into your substructure the thoughts
emerge we don't know what processes of
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak from the core of your
being
we don't understand any of that we don't
even conceptualize that but i believe
that you can feel that and i learned
some of that from reading carl rogers by
the way who's a great clinician
because he talked about mental health in
part as a coherence between the
the the spiritual or the or the abstract
and the physical that the two things
were aligned
and and there's a lot of idea of
alignment in in psychoanalytic and
clinical thinking
but anyways i decided that i would start
practicing
not saying things that would make me
weak and what happened was that i
had to stop saying almost everything
that i was saying
i would say 95 of it as a hell of a
shock to wake up and
i mean this was over a few months but
it's a hell of a shock to wake up and
realize that
you're mostly dead wood
it's a shock you know and you might
think well do you really want all of
that to burn off it's like well there's
nothing left but a little husk
five percent of you it's like well if
that five percent is
solid then maybe that's exactly what you
want to have happen
adopt the mode of
authentic being and that is something
like
refusing to participate in the lie
in deception in the lie to orient your
speech as much as you can
towards the truth and to take
responsibility for your own life and
perhaps also for the lives of other
people
and there's something about that that's
meaningful
and responsible and noble but also
serves to mitigate the very suffering
that
produces say the nihilism or the flea
into the arms of flea
or or the or the escape into the arms of
totalitarians to begin with
you need something to shelter you
against your own vulnerability
you can think about the world this way
you can think about it as your orderly
little plan
that's a place and you can think about
it as the place that things that disrupt
your plan comes from
that's another place this is a bigger
place than this
because there's an endless number of
things that can disrupt your plan and
only a tiny number of them that can
you know that will help you work it out
so part of the question then too is like
are you the friend of your plan or are
you the friend of the thing that
disrupts your plan
and i would say you should work to
become the friend of the thing that
disrupts your plan because there's a lot
of that
and then if you become the friend of the
thing that disrupts your plan
then you be you start to develop
strength in proportion to the
to the disruptive force and that's
really what you want you want to be able
to implement your plan obviously but you
want to be able to
take on the consequences of error
and learn from it and then then you win
constantly because even if something
goes sideways
you think there's something to be
derived from this
that's wisdom fundamentally plan a life
you'd like to have
and and you do that partly by referring
to social norms that's more or less
rescuing your father from the belly of
the whale but the way
other way you do that is by having a
little conversation with yourself
about as if you don't really know who
you are because you know what you're
like you won't do what you're told you
won't do what you tell yourself to do
you must have noticed that it's like
you're a bad employee
and a worse boss and both of those work
you know for you you don't know what you
want to do and then when you tell
yourself what to do you don't do it
anyways you should fire yourself and
find someone else to be but but you know
what my point is is that you have to
understand that you're not your own
servant so to speak you're someone that
you have to negotiate with and that's
and you're someone that you want to
present the opportunity of having a good
life to
and that's hard for people because they
don't like themselves very much
so you know they're always like cracking
the whip and then procrastinating and
cracking the whip and then
procrastinating and it's like god
it's so boring and such a pathetic way
of spending your time
if you configure your life so that what
you are
genuinely doing is aiming at the highest
possible good then the things that you
need
to to survive
and to thrive on a day-to-day basis will
deliver themselves to you that's a
hypothesis
and it's not some simple hypothesis
right because what it basically says is
if you dare to do the most difficult
thing that you can conceptualize
your life will work out better than it
will if you do anything else
well how are you going to find out if
that's true well it's a kierkegaardian
leap of faith there's no way you're
going to find out whether or not that's
true unless you do it
so no one no one can tell you either
because
just because it works for someone else i
mean that's interesting and all that but
it's no proof that it'll work for you
you have to be all in in this game
there is no more effective way of
operating in the world than to
conceptualize the highest good that you
can
and then strive to attain it there's no
more practical pathway to the kind of
success
that you could have if you actually knew
what success was
the world shifts itself around
your aim because you're you're a
creature that has a name
you have to have a name in order to do
something you're an aiming creature you
look
at a point and you move towards it it's
built right into you
and so you have a name well let's say
your aim is the highest possible aim
well then so that sets up the world
around you
it organizes all of your perceptions it
organizes what you see
and you don't see it organizes your
emotions and your motivations
so you organize yourself around that aim
and then what happens is
the day manifests itself as a set of
challenges and problems
and if you solve them properly then you
stay on the pathway towards that ape
and you can concentrate on the on the on
the day and so that way you get to have
your cake and eat it too
because you can you can point into the
distance the far distance
and you can live in the day
and it seems to me that that's that
makes every moment of the day
super charged with meaning that that's
how because if everything that you're
doing every day is related to the
highest possible aim that you can
conceptualize
well that's the very definition of the
meaning that would sustain you in your
life
thank you guys so much for watching i
made this video because dude what
two one two asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you are going
to profile next check out the link in
the description and you can go
and cast your vote i also love to know
which clip resonated the most with you
what lesson are you going to take from
this video and
immediately apply to your life or to
your business somehow
leave it down in the comments below i'm
really curious to find out what you have
to say i also want to give a quick shout
out to nathan from the productivity game
channel nathan thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word
and making that awesome youtube video on
your channel about it
i really appreciate the support man and
i'm so glad to enjoy that
carmichael states that there is one word
that defines who you are
connects all the things in your life
that make you come alive
and will help you escape the chains of
mediocrity thank you guys so much for
watching
i believe in you i hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever
your one word is much love
no one can live without a routine you
just forget that if you guys don't have
a routine
i would recommend like you get one going
because
you cannot be mentally healthy without a
routine
you need to pick a time to get up
whatever time you want but pick one
and stick to it because otherwise you
dis-regulate your circadian rhythms
and they regulate your mood it's
disciplined it's predictable
and bloody well stick to it you're going
to be way healthier and happier and
saner if you do that and then the other
thing that you need
because this is one of the things the
psychoanalyst got wrong i think is that
they overestimated the degree to which
sanity was a consequence of internal
of being properly structured internally
you know
because from the psychoanalytic point of
view you're sort of an ego and that ego
is inside you
and of course it rests on an unconscious
structure but the purpose of
psychoanalysis
is to sort out that unconscious
structure and the ego on top of it and
to make you a
fully functioning and autonomous
individual but there's a problem with
that because
the reason that you're saying as a fully
functional and autonomous human being
isn't because you've organized your
psyche even though that's important
the reason that you're saying if you're
away if you have a well organized
unconscious and ego is because other
people can tolerate having you around
for reasonably extensive periods of time
and will cuff you across the back of the
head every time you do something so
stupid that people will dislike you
permanently if you continue
and so what people are doing to each
other all the time just
non-stop is broadcasting sanity signals
back and forth right it's like
you smile at people if they're well if
they're not not only
behaving properly but behaving in a way
that you would like to see them continue
to behave
you frown at them if they're not you
ignore them if they're not you shun them
you
you roll your eyes at them you manifest
a disgust face you don't listen to them
you interrupt them
you won't cooperate with them you won't
compete with them it's like
you're blasting signals at other people
about how to regulate their behavior
so frequently well it just makes up all
of your social interaction
that's why we face each other and we
have emotional displays on our face and
we're looking at each other's eyes and
we know exactly we know as much as we
can about what's going on with each
other
given that we don't have immediate
access to the contents of their
consciousness and so
partly what you're doing with your
routine is establishing yourself
as a credible reliable trustworthy
potentially interesting human being who
isn't going to do anything too erratic
at any moment
and everyone else is around there
tapping you into shape making sure that
that's exactly what you are
and that's how you stay sane and so what
happens to people too if they don't have
a routine
and they get isolated as they start to
drift and they drift badly because
the world is too complicated for you to
keep it organized
all by yourself you just cannot do it
so a lot of our so we outsource the
problem of sanity
and it's very intelligent that we
outsource the problem of sanity because
sanity is an impossibly complex problem
and so the way that we manage the
incredibly complex problem is we have
a very large number of brains working
simultaneously on the problem
all the time